So this burst utilitzation, as Stratton and Company call it,
is usually the most critical factor to optimize for global memory performance
and that's where the examples of a ray of structure, the structure of a ray comes in.
But there are also subtler issues like partition camping that can occasionally rear their heads.
So as before, I'll use the ninja icon to indicate topics
that the average GPU programmer probably won't need to concern themselves with.
Now a more sophisticated example of the data layout transformation technique
is something called the array of structures of tiled arrays, or ASTA.
This technique can address issues like partition camping
and can potentially achieve even better bandwidth utilization on a wider range of architectures.
So you'll find a reference in the supplementary materials.